hairy's very keen for baby statics to be
brought up in the countryside but he's
also keen to strike out on his own well
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex have
finally done just that
a royal source confirms to ET the Prince
Harry and Megan Markel have moved out of
Kensington Palace and into their new
Frogmore cottage home it's a new chapter
right according to our source the
residence was a gift from the Queen
which the royal duo has been renovating
since the fall for a reported three
million dollar but just when you thought
Megan and Harry we're getting some
freedom think again our source says
frogz more cottage is merely a stone's
throw away from the queen's windsor
castle where the parents-to-be are due
to send a stir megan is expected to give
birth at the end of April or beginning
of May and our source says she's feeling
great adding that she and Harry quote
couldn't be more excited about starting
their life together with their new baby
and are keen that their child will be
able to enjoy their privacy away from
the goldfish bowl we've previously been
told that the couple wants to give their
child as normal an upbringing as
possible and according to our source the
extensive gardens at Frogmore cottage
will offer Bibi Sussex freedom from the
paparazzi to play outdoors and enjoy a
wonderful childhood as someone who is
about to become a father I'm acutely
aware of our shared responsibility to
make this world more resilient and its
inhabitants more accountable for the
next generation and while Megan has been
busy prepping for motherhood and
juggling her extensive charity work our
source says she's also been involved
every step of the way in remodeling
their new home renovations include
double panel windows and noise proofing
to conservatory extensions a new kitchen
several fireplaces and of course the
nursery the nursery itself is going to
be very modern don't expect to see any
baby pink or baby blue apparently is
going to be a monochrome palette and
whites and grays thesaurus adds that
Megan and Harry are over the moon about
their first child being
born I'm told that she's upbeat and that
she's happy rumor has it Meg's mom Doria
Ragland was expected to relocate to
England to help with babies Sussex
but our source says that won't be the
case adding that Frogmore cottage does
however afford them the space for Doria
to spend extended visits as she gets to
know her first grandchild and it seems
as though Doria has taught her daughter
well a friend of Megan's tells ET that
the former actress will be a fantastic
mother adding she is so wonderful with
children and Megan and Harry are both so
excited
you